Mi sento come se avessi degli spaghetti
cotti sulla fronte Salve sto facendo i
cazzi miei ma questo è il mio lavoro e
faccio lo youtuber li dovrei anche
guardare eh la telecamera Ciao ragazzi
capelli a parte ragazzi oggi parliamo di
una situazione l'avete letto dal titolo
però vi spiego questa è una ve la
racconto perché è successa una roba
assurda molto particolare molto
divertente per voi ma non per me Allora
succede tutto un mesetto fa più o meno
no Quando è avvenuto l'arresto appunto
di Matteo Messina Denaro Succede questo
mi sveglio mi sveglio la mattina
tranquillo Allora ragazzi io durante la
notte spengo il telefono lo spengo
perché evito che almeno alle 5:00 alle
6:00 del mattino quando tutti i miei
amici che stanno in discoteca mi mandano
selfie e foto della loro nightlife
Milanese E io invece sto dormendo come
l'orso Yoghi mi sveglio la mattina e
attacco il wi-fi quindi accendo
sostanzialmente il telefono Schiaccio
questo magico tasto eh del sì quello
cioè io ho me stesso come sfondo perché
sembra che mi son cagato addosso Quindi
la tengo perché mi fa ridere Non
giudicate schiaccio il magico tasto
wi-fi e il telefono esplode
letteralmente di notifiche ma esplode
diversamente dal solito vedo con
particolare attenzione Tra l'altro che
le notifiche di Instagram fanno questo
ma tanto Cioè sembrava una roba una
catena infinita e apro i dm a quel punto
No perché dico ma cosa sta succedendo È
la notifica è una ed è questa hanno
arrestato tuo padre un sacco di messaggi
hanno arrestato tuo padre così mi arriva
un messaggio così dico vabbè ce ne sei
una presa per il culo me ne sono
arrivati tantissimi sono arrivati un
milione di messaggi hanno arrestato tuo
padre ma è tuo padre quello al TG cioè
delle cose No ragazzi sono io sono
svenuto cioè lì sul momento stavo avendo
un mancamento E tu che cazzo è successo
ma poi mio padre cioè mio padre non fa
una sega nella sua vita mio padre che
lui suona non sapete sono in una band
Comunque lui fa band dove suona divano
di calcio cioè fa questa questo ping
pong un po' strano ho detto minchia e
così è diventata la Ben Bentornati i
Rammstein Cioè non so se hanno pippato
sul tavolo mentre suona non ho capito
cos'è successo quindi il panico
aggiuntivo e non era solo questo era
anche perché di mezzo c'era la parola TG
quindi era anche fin da sul TG sta roba
e che non mi veniva in mente che cosa
potesse essere successo panico ma panico
quello veramente ragazzi Vero cioè io vi
giuro ho vissuto un momento terribile
finché Appunto non mi metto ad aprire
idm dove il 90% di DM erano solo hanno
arrestato tuo padre quindi non si capiva
lì quindi il panico che continua finché
a un certo punto non apro il DM di un
mio amico che mi manda la foto
dell'arresto di Matteo Messina Denaro e
mi manda la foto dicendo hanno arrestato
quest'uomo qua che sembra tuo padre
perché io apro sta foto qua e dico
Vediamo apre ed effettivamente Era Ugo
Allora c'è una foto in partita perché
non è non è in tutte le foto mestiere
denaro è uguale a mio padre ma in questa
foto in particolare che penso che sia
quella che che metterò come copertina
del video è proprio i lineamenti sono
uguali potrebbe veramente sembrare mio
padre Cioè se mio padre mi Abbiamo
trovato una foto così cioè io avrei
detto Ma che cosa stai facendo cioè
l'avrei veramente scambiato per mio
padre quindi da lì succedono Un po' di
cose eh succede che mi arriva un
messaggio direttamente da mio padre Eh
ve lo faccio leggere mi arriva un
messaggio di mio padre tra l'altro
inoltrato quindi gliel'hanno inoltrato e
mi fa per un po' dovrò assentarvi
bellissimo Io qua già sapevo vedete
della tipo mezzogiorno e mezza Quindi
qua ormai avevo già capito tutto però
effettivamente questa foto
[Musica]
È incredibile e qua finisce la parte del
panico Sostanzialmente però di lì a poco
succede un'altra cosa da lì in poi è
diventata una roba virale su Tik Tok
perché ovunque su Tik Tok spuntava la
foto dei di Matteo Messina Denaro
affiancato a mio padre Infatti è pieno
di Tik Tok Così il padre di Favij in
realtà è Matteo Messina Denaro Mi spiace
che è arrivato un po' in ritardo lui una
settimana fa in realtà è un Meme che è
andato molto prima però meglio tardi che
mai sono impazzito aspettate di vedere
la foto che vi mostro tra poco Matteo
Messina Denaro un po' stratitante della
mafia che è stato arrestato solo adesso
Favij c'è sempre nascosto tutto ciò ha
nascosto lui suo padre cioè Matteo
Messina Denaro ragazzi Questa è la prova
Qua abbiamo Favij Qua abbiamo suo padre
Matteo Messina Denaro questo del padre
di Favij arrestato qui in casa sua un
poeta ha sbagliato tutto quello poteva
sbagliare perché ha fatto il video molto
più tardi perché ormai era cioè potrebbe
essere un altro paio di anni fa Lorenzo
davvero questo da tennis poteva essere
una persona qualunque quella foto lì la
cosa che mi fa ancora più strano di
tutta sta facendo è che i bambini su Tik
Tok hanno veramente creduto che Matteo
Messina Denaro fosse veramente mio padre
quindi è pieno di commenti del tipo non
so se ironia ma Favi e Matteo non hanno
lo stesso cognome Tik Tok ragazzi Tik
Tok io non ho smesso da una vita di
guardare i commenti in generale ma
quando esiste Tik Tok non vale più
niente Cioè veramente la gente Zero IQ
allora perché non si chiama Matteo
Ostuni Ma ragazzi ma non ha lo stesso
cognome con la senza h Comunque è pieno
pieno di sta roba cioè Vi giuro Ragazzi
ma sbagliate la foto Ah lo rimetto
perché lo hanno bannato Secondo me hanno
iniziato a bannare tutti i Meme del
genere perché la popolazione che si è
fatta la foto con mio padre sia il papà
di Favij cosa
ma che ma cos'è
ma perché c'è questa cosa cos'è una foto
con mio padre Poi Glow up Ma perché
parte tutto dalla foto di mio padre
anestected questo finale con Tik Tok
regala perle Vabbè ragazzi era un breve
video per raccontarvi una vicenda che ho
realmente vissuto male Lui sta molto
male perché io vi assicuro che
Svegliarsi la mattina sembrava tipo
Scherzi a parte sembra Allora ragazzi io
poi tra l'altro Strava non me l'ho mai
detta Però io costantemente nella mia
vita Credo di vivere costantemente come
se fossi su Scherzi a parte Nel senso
che io ho sempre pensato dal momento in
cui sono diventato Popolare ho detto è
callà prima o poi qualcuno se ne esce
facendomi uno scherzo Ok tipo appunto
Scherzi a parte di quelli tipo che ne so
che tipo questo poteva essere uno
scherzo Della serie hanno incarcerato
tuo padre e roba magari è tutto montato
Quindi io quando mi succedono nella vita
delle cose strane tendo a pensare che
sia uno scherzo ma tante cose che mi
sono successe ad esempio vi faccio un
esempio quando ho preso la patente che
sono è stato bocciato sette volte
diciamola sta cosa che fa sempre ridere
è stato Cioè sette volte la patente Sì
fa ridere va bene a me non fa ridere un
cazzo la sesta o la settima volta che mi
hanno bocciato la patente io che mi
bocciavano sempre per un errore in più
no Quando tornavo in macchina Ovviamente
non guidavo io perché non c'avevo la
patente quando stavo per tornare a casa
io Mi guardavo intorno dicevo No ma non
possono avermi rimboccato Secondo me è
uno scherzo e quindi Mi guardavo intorno
perché pensavo ci fossero telecamere
nascoste Ok tipo quelle microcamere no
telecamera perché so che prima o poi
succederà lo so e quindi quando mi sono
svegliato e ho letto tuo padre è stato
arrestato tuo padre è stato arrestato la
prima cosa che la primissima cosa che ho
pensato ho detto ok Mi stanno facendo eh
Siamo su Scherzi mi stanno facendo uno
scherzo però la cosa strana è che era
uno scherzo troppo Benatia architettato
perché me lo dicevano eh amici
d'infanzia compagni di classe gente in
dm che non c'entrava niente Quindi zero
correlazioni quindi lì per lì ho
abbandonato subito l'ipotesi Questa è
stata la vicenda top dell'ultimo mese No
mio padre non è Matteo Messina Denaro
Comunque spero che vi sia piaciuto l'ho
registrato con la webcam questo perché
devo resettare tutta rubrica videocamera
In conclusione ragazzi Ci tengo a dirvi
breve news prima di concludere stanno
per uscire Sons of the forest che è Il
sequel di no scusate il prequel di the
forest però comunque il nuovo capitolo
di the forest quindi il nuovo the forest
esce la prossima settimana lo farò al
100%. e a fine marzo ma qua ne passa
ancora un po' uscirà appunto Resident
Evil 4 remake porterò assolutamente
tutto il gameplay stanno un po' tornando
Gameplay Ma perché stanno uscendo roba
in particolare che mi interessano quindi
aspettatevi Gameplay lasciate queste
belle notizie quindi non potete non dire
di essere contenti Ci vediamo in un
prossimo video e come sempre Beh ragazzi